you know when it's okay to wear a
t-shirt with a jacket when it's a portal
to shirt
alright given the choice between a John
Carter review and a men and black 3
trailer review I will do men in black 3
trailer review although John Carter is
coming but in the world of instant
gratification a two and a half minute
trailer or a forced Disney franchise
alright so the new trailer for the new
men in black movie men in black 3 is
that we've heard about men in black 3
for like the last 10 years at a point we
were like that's never gonna happen now
it's happening in a couple months in
fact not too far away so in men in black
3 it shows Agent J it shows Will Smith
he's doing this thing he's being all
Will Smith ish and something happens
Agent K Tommy Lee Jones gets blinked out
of existence apparently something
happened in the past he was killed he
died not sure why but I'm pretty sure it
has something to do with that guy hyouta
copyright well probably not but it
should so now agent J has to go back to
1969 to get help from one man George
Dobie Bush how do you know my name
because you were WNW alright you bet
alright cuz I was there personally I
think Josh Brolin is gonna kill it as
young Tommy Lee Jones because he looks
sounds and acts just like Tommy Lee
Jones just younger he's the perfect
young agent K 29 yeah some city miles on
you and it's apparent that tubby it was
his audition video thank you the candy
shop I'll let you lick the lollipop a
couple things about this though agent k
died like 30 or 40 years ago wouldn't
agent J not be M in a black agent that's
a weird little paradox right there maybe
they'll explain it I imagine they would
because that would be the big thing on
people's minds yeah I'm down I played
Chrono Trigger Chrono Cross I watch
Fringe I know about this kind of [ __ ]
but I like this premise because there
are some really good opportunities when
you have a light-hearted movie like an
action comedy that deals with time it
might just be awesome it could be crap
but the odds are it will be fun because
you have some really good opportunities
for some pop-culture references of the
past like it shows Andy Warhol's a Men
in Black agent trying to blow my cover
Oh Andy Warhol is one of us who's the
dumbest whoa you know I want no problem
pimp slap in the shiznit out of Andy
Warhol why funny thing is no Rip Torn
he knows that I guess he's not it maybe
Rip Torn was busy doing other stuff so
Will Smith Josh Brolin great actors a
good premise some time travel and an
action comedy yeah yeah yeah how does
that not
Jocelin i remember though the minute
black movies are like 90 minutes long
there are they feel short men in
black'''s funny it's good it's
entertaining but it is short when you
add time travel that automatically has
to bump up the run time of the movie to
15-20 minutes more a lot of time travel
stuff to wrap up it's just how it goes
so the men in black 3 trailer have you
seen it what do you think about it have
you seen the men in black movies what's
your favorite one of the two whatever to
any and all those questions comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]